and it certainly has been a very trying
time for our educators not just the last
year and some of the things that are
going on in the school district right
now but the past two years during the
pandemic so this week
simply a week to say thank you for all
you do absolutely a big thank you to all
of our educators bianca holman joining
us live this morning with how you can
recognize the educators in your child's
life bianca good morning
hey good morning so our teachers are
juggling a lot right now from school
violence to teacher shortage but this is
the time in the week to take a step back
and say thank you for all that they do
and share our gratitude and share our
appreciation for investing in our kids
now the national pta they created
teacher appreciation week this year it's
important to show your appreciation for
your educators even at the middle and
high school level not just for our
elementary school educators
we spoke with rebecca garcia of nevada
pta and she says it's so important to
make sure teachers know we value their
work that they do the effort that they
put into preparing our children for the
future
i think teacher appreciation week is a
good time to stop
and make sure that as a parent as a
family member you're acknowledging the
hard work that teachers do you're
saying thank you and encouraging your
kids to do the same
garcia also says it's not all about the
gifts flowers gift cards and things like
that but a handwritten note that can
make a huge impact individual schools of
course are doing their own thing and
celebrating in their own ways but there
are tons of stores like barnes and noble
and j crew national stores that have
discounts for educators this week up
next in the next half hour we're going
to talk with an educator about his
experience and what this week means to
him and also some things here locally
that are in benefit of and celebrating
our educators that are across the valley
bianca holman live local now